He is strong with the force but he will not
be safe until he masters his abilities.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my mandalorian season 3 top 10
predictions there are a bunch of things
that they set up and did not resolve big questions
that they raised but did not answer during
the season 2 episode 8 finale so we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes
i will be doing mandalorian season 3 bonus
videos and bonus videos for all the other
spin-off series like the book of boba fett
as well as the ahsoka tano series and everything
else that they announce and i'll explain what
the schedule is going to be when everything
is going to premiere we're still doing the
giveaway for disney plus memberships all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
just leave all your predictions for season
3 of mando on the video careful for spoilers
for everything that happened on the mandalorian
so far if you haven't seen any of the episodes
but we'll start with number 10 there will
be a small time jump for all the characters
in the final couple of seasons so not just
season 2 to season 3 but also season 3 to
season four and season four to season five
and they'll just use that to help get the
main characters to the huge grand admiral
thrawn netflix defenders or avengers in-game
crossover event between all the different
spin-off shows a little bit faster because
there's a lot of leg work that they have to
do to develop the characters to where they
need to be before they can actually defeat
thrawn and in addition to a lot of these spin-off
series that they've announced like the ahsoka
tano series the rangers the new republic and
now this book of boba fett series there'll
probably be other one-off mini-series along
the way like just one small season of a couple
episodes of side characters some of those
have already been rumored i'll explain those
later in the video too but number nine particularly
this is all to also speed up the whole luke
skywalker grogu jedi training plot i would
say mostly actually for him just because of
the way that character works grogu is both
the best thing and one of the long term most
difficult things for the show to do or will
do because the way he ages the way the character
works year to year he doesn't really change
he's still going to look like this little
kid in another 20 years when these characters
are starting to get really really old and
part of the magic of the way they use that
character on the show right now is it's better
to have him not speak for instance like if
he started being really verbal like yoda when
he got older they lose a lot of the magic
of moments like this in the finale like his
communication seems much more impactful when
he reaches out and touches mando's helmet
and he instantly knows what that means taking
the helmet off so grogu can finally see his
face then his tiny little hand reaches out
and touches him and everyone starts crying
i'm not crying you're crying even mando is
crying so you don't really want to change
that aspect of the character but like luke
skywalker said talent without training is
nothing and he won't be safe until he becomes
a full jedi knight finishes his training and
when ahsoka tano was telling us about his
backstory at the jedi temple if you think
about his time as a padawan during the prequel
era he was a padawan for like 20 years before
revenge of the sith happened in order 66 and
it really only seemed like he'd begun to tap
into his potential so it's going to take a
long long time for him to become a full jedi
knight way longer than someone say like luke
skywalker who matures physically much faster
so that's why it makes more sense to do some
kind of time jumps to just speed through some
of the day-to-day for that so that all the
characters get to the good stuff but number
eight that being said during the mandalorian
season 3 we probably won't see a ton of cg
uncanny valley luke skywalker mark hamill
isn't suddenly going to become a main character
on the show but the show also isn't going
to get rid of grogu they're getting better
with their cg face replacement i understand
why they want to keep the original trilogy
actors and not recast but it's still crazy
expensive to do those kinds of things and
the more they do those scenes the less magical
the less impactful those needle drop moments
become but think about it this way even though
grogu left mando and the show is called the
mandalorian being a mandalorian isn't so much
about your dna that was what i think that
whole conversation with boba fett was about
like you know mandalorian like she talks about
jango fett not being his father but being
his donor and then donating his dna to become
another clone way back during season one the
armorer said you are now a clan of two a clan
of mandalorians eventually i think they will
reveal as a lot of people have theorized that
the title of the show the mandalorian also
refers not just to denjarin's mandalorian
character but also to grosgu himself he's
also worth way too much to the show metaphorically
for a number of different reasons like yes
you skipped through a lot of the day-to-day
jedi training but they make so much money
on grogu merchandise that they're not going
to suddenly take him out of the equation and
just not sell new grogu merchandise so because
he left mando though we probably won't see
quite as much of grogu as we normally would
he won't be traveling around in mando's hip
pocket everywhere he goes but moff gideon
had that big speech with him when he was waving
the darksaber in his face you're getting pretty
good at that but it makes you oh so sleepy
because he's untrained eventually we'll probably
see him use his forced telekinesis without
getting super tired super quickly and as a
follow-up to that number seven yeah we will
see the beginnings of luke skywalker's jedi
school a very very early version of it it
probably won't look anything like the one
we saw in kylo ren's memories the one he and
the knights of ren burned down when he came
back to kill everyone in a lot of you since
he went off with luke skywalker now have been
doing the math on this and you're like wait
a minute obviously grogu is going to live
for another 850 years so he'd be alive during
the new trilogy does this mean that kylo ren
eventually kills grogu if he killed everyone
at luke's school and i think we can all agree
that that would be the most crap story twist
ever here's this amazing character let's kill
him off as fast as possible after this really
hopeful moment an amazing goodbye that they
just had this moment was all about grogu going
to serve his higher calling like grogu is
the future of the jedi order he'll watch over
it for the next 850 years like yoda saw hundreds
and hundreds of generations of jedi come and
go over his 900 years grogo is not yoda but
he's the next yoda-like grand master jedi
to come along or eventual grand master jedi
so yes it's probably safe to say grogu will
not be killed by kylo ren or the knights of
ren like luke skywalker's other jedi padawans
but eventually of course jon favreau and dave
filoni will have to explain what he was doing
during the events of the new movies number
six when season 3 begins though mando will
probably still have the darksaber but he and
Bo Katan will probably have called some sort
of temporary truce like he is the classic
reluctant hero in this situation the luke
skywalker prototype mono myth character remember
luke skywalker's arc during a new hope obi-wan
kenobi gives luke anakin skywalker's lightsaber
and tells him you should come to alderaan
with me and luke's like i can't do that i
have all these chores i have to be a moisture
farmer help my uncle owen and on peru i don't
have time to go fight in any star wars cut
to one act later in the movie and boom he's
training as a jedi on the millennium falcon
on his way to a cloud of dust that used to
be alderaan everyone pressed f in the chat
to pay respects a version of that arc just
happened to mando during season w Bo Katan
tells him come fight in our war and help your
people fellow mandalorians reclaim their heritage
take back what was taken from them and he's
like i don't have time for that i have to
take grogu to the jedi now that he's done
that he's also agreed as per the terms of
their deal at the beginning of the episode
to help Bo Katan and the other mandalorians
take back the planet so number five as a lot
of you have also theorized because mando still
has the darksaber even though he doesn't want
it another classic trope he has the strongest
claim to the throne of mandalore which kind
of makes him the new mandalore the new leader
of their people unlikely hero gets caught
up in galactic war then becomes an iconic
leader through circumstances outside of his
control but Bo Katan is still the one calling
the shots at least if you asked her who was
in charge she would say that she's in charge
even though she'll probably just ask mando
to go along with her plan and use him as a
symbol to rally more mandalorians out of hiding
to her banners her whole plan right now is
to build their forces before they can attempt
to retake the planet so mando is really useful
to her as a symbol look mandalorians now have
the darksaber again come rally to our banner
and we'll retake what was taken from us is
part of that plot though number four the working
title for the mandalorian season 3 while they're
filming episodes is buccaneer which is a spanish
word for pirate and during season 2 episode
3 the heiress the imperials were calling Bo
Katan and the night albus pirates so it sounds
like a lot of season 3 will be mando living
the pirates life as they go around gaining
resources through legitimate and not so legitimate
ways but the title of the show is still the
mandalorian it's just that instead of following
him on bounty hunting side quests week to
week while he was with grogu the plot follows
more of what he's doing with the other mandalorians
and Bo Katan becomes a bigger character than
she was during season 2.
he's still the main character but here's the
thing with all those spin-off shows that they
announce number 3 cara dune spent the whole
episode talking about the information that
she and the new republic want to get from
moff gideon because he's former imperial security
bureau and they're literally the information
gathering arm of the empire they deal in all
the secrets so that's why he's such an encyclopedia
of knowledge the new republic name drop during
that conversation is probably just the teaser
that most of that plot will be covered on
the rangers of the new republic spin-off series
they don't have a premiere date for that yet
but it'll probably be sometime during 2022
along with the ahsoka tano series like i said
the ahsoka tano series will probably mostly
be heard searching for grand admiral thrawn
in the outer rim and ezra bridger will also
probably see more of those star wars rebels
animated characters come into live action
maybe rex is still alive if tamara morrison
is doing all this boba fett stuff maybe he
could also come back as an older version of
rex there's also a rumor that in addition
to this book of boba fett miniseries like
obviously it's going to be a much smaller
series than one of the normal big seasons
there was a scooper recently daniel richman
that was claiming that they would do a book
of bo katan miniseries one-off as well but
it'd obviously be much smaller than a normal
big season for a full-blown spin-off so what's
probably happening with their grand design
in these crossover shows is that the shows
that they announced at the disney investor
meeting the ahsoka series in the new republic
series will be full-blown shows they'll get
like 8 episodes per season but the book of
boba fett and the other one-off mini-series
will get way less than that and that's probably
why they're not billing them as full-blown
series number two regardless all the characters
from all these different series that they've
introduced in the new ones that they will
eventually introduce will all cross over to
each other's shows that's why they're all
set during the same time period it's just
that for example on the ahsoka tano series
we'll probably get way more of ahsoka's flashbacks
to the clone wars when she was younger maybe
force ghost anakin skywalker with hayden christensen
and present-day maybe some darth vader flashbacks
whereas when ahsokitano crosses over into
mandalorian episodes you just won't see quite
as much of her but all the plots of all the
shows are slowly pushing towards this eventual
grand admiral thrawn avengers endgame final
battle in a couple years but we probably won't
see him on screen until maybe like the end
of the mandalorian season 3 as a big wtf surprise
or the season finale of the ahsoka tano series
moff gideon has just been captured and it
seems like he's going to spend a lot of the
first season of the new republic series going
full hannibal lecter in a prison cell while
they try to get information out of him but
he'll also show up on the mandalorian season
3 as well probably in number one mando will
probably come close to seeing grogu again
during season 3 but they'll probably leave
a big full reunion for further off luke skywalker
said he'd be in danger until he finished his
training and that's going to take a long time
so for all of season 3 he'll still be in a
lot of potential danger and we'll learn more
about what maf gideon and grand admiral thrawn
were planning to do with his blood when they
said that there's potential within him to
bring order of the galaxy that feels like
they're hinting at the jedi cloning plot from
the original thrawn trilogy they probably
won't do that exact plot but it just feels
like they want to use grogu's dna to create
clones that are force sensitive that they
can control like dark troopers like dr pershing
kept talking about eliminating the weaknesses
from their troops and in the scene from episode
four he kept talking about the test subjects
not being able to handle injections of grogu's
blood so they're trying to perfect that cloning
process right now just in terms of when all
the episodes are coming we know that the boba
fett show the book of boba fett will start
in december next year lucasfilm has said that
the mandalorian season 3 will start christmas
day next year while i was finishing this video
lucasfilm just announced that john favreau
is going to be going on good morning america
for a really big interview to talk about the
finale on monday so i'll do a video for whatever
he talks about but they said that he's going
to clarify a lot of these big details but
everyone post all your predictions in the
comments below i will do a full luke skywalker
video next so as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you should see that when i
post it leave all your requests in the comments
too congratulations alex 102 539 you're the
giveaway winner from my last big video please
email me on the about page of my channel so
i can get your contact details everyone click
here for that full mandalorian season 2 episode
8 finale video and click here for the book
of boba fett teaser in that big post credits
scene thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe this is the way!